[Music]
the idea of parallel universes is a sexy
and exciting one and it might even be
true in fact there's different ways in
which it could be true there are at
least three different notions that
scientists play with in a respectable
way that correspond to our sort of
informal science fictiony idea of a
parallel universe the one that is the
most modern one is literally parallel
universes if you believe that there are
extra dimensions of space besides the
three that we know about right up down
left right forward backward but there
could be parallel three-dimensional
spaces next to us in that extra
dimension that we just don't see we
don't know whether that's true or not
but we think about it again
that's what theoretical physicists do
for a living there's also the
cosmological multiverse the idea that
very very far away from us there's
regions of our universe that just looks
so different that we refer to them as
different universes and then finally
there are the many worlds of quantum
mechanics which is actually the most
likely to be true of any of these
scenarios the idea that when you make an
observation of a quantum mechanical
system like an atom or a particle
quantum mechanics doesn't tell you
definitively what the answer will be it
tells you the probability of getting one
outcome or the other and the many-worlds
idea says that actually both of those
possible answers come true if you
observe a particle here or there there's
a world in which it was there and you
saw it there and another world in which
it was over here and you saw it over
here and every time a quantum mechanical
interaction takes place our whole
universe splits into multiple worlds